welcome to this video playing anger
anger boy probably so not the good fire
going for my Bishop f4 line that Hilda's
pretty decent results okay hmm yeah
sometimes I go h3 to avoid the pin but
whoa so he lets me take on b7 stead
right candy can you trap my queen down
if I go Quinn bezel should move cheeks
maybe you can quit b6 is kind of
annoying and so let's do this okay now I
can go with this typical c5 medulla but
where pieces are not very well
positioned for that maybe let's do this
and get the e porn yeah I like that more
c4 c5 my pieces are not Val positioned
you can see one is wrong and so on okay
so this is a temp oh I always expected
to lose the tempo there with the bishop
move yeah I'm probably hmm probably not
not threatening is seven for real
it's got that counter idea on be too um
so what does he doing
yeah I'd like to be likes to play you
five it's difficult to prevent i mean i
can go F for maybe it's / maybe not so
bad at for Bishop to age for black seems
okay he's got no bad piece and decent
coordination k
Janice pawn structure is kind of weird
but controlling quite a decent amount of
squares so should be so bad see 5 yard
to take it and now just castles I guess
interesting maybe here for 95
hmm before or cie he maybe wants to go
to he maybe wants to go to have five hmm
i wonder if night c5 is a move maybe
come on let's do that trying to
accelerate my play there a little bit
cual structures from damage but i don't
know if this is supported
Oh doesn't you have to take basically or
queen too okay
mm maybe can go b6 here I mean ok.can
taking us what I expect most
yeah this is what i meant with speeding
up things now i'm a bit quicker there 98
so I'm trying to prevent invasion okay
not quite working we should be 75 was
what I was looking for
doesn't work he can go King evade at the
end of that line will be five that also
not does not work or not does not help
and this certain 75
yeah i think it's it's still equal can
go Rupe the aid or something something
like that Jim I don't know maybe black
is completely fine yeah more than equal
and I don't I don't doubt that though
mmm well why am I going at five he can
take it right I was thinking I get back
but I don't yep I didn't get it back I
was a bad idea I come on I usually
switch the sound off and really should
i'm always totally irritated by the
phone calls so let's see do i get this
back yeah this way I get it better yeah
this is kind of irritating maybe he got
irritated by the phone call
SMR from being a pawn down it switch to
me being a pawn up that's good
black resigns wow what a weird game what
a weird game so let's see ya around here
should be should be equal ish yeah
injured is always on on equal not quite
sure about my five new that cannot be a
good idea the engine thinks it's okay
interesting group d 2 though he should
probably do this would you tune new a4
yeah it seems that i'm not i didn't get
myself into huge trouble getting one
back here maybe but I didn't really see
those consequences clearly when I've
been updated and here here it gets
bahria he has to go check check and move
the night still seems to be kind of
equal but here basically just winning
I'm taking all the points all of them
amazing yeah there was it was kind of
kind of lucky kind of a lucky win and I
wonder about this opening just quickly
for you go back here I one day ever
could've chica not be seven but I don't
think I could have done that this is
this I thought I thought it's still
difficult to do sorry something against
97 the engine thinks it's equal
surprisingly enough oopsie to
this is a point down now I didn't see
that one no here yeah maybe I should
take I'm not quite short this is this
kind of thing might that might be a
slight advantage it I like that a little
bit a little bit better than my then my
am may game choice yeah okay thanks for
watching